rolling seen one Bubba take one mark OMG  its forest time for now I'll see you  tomorrow yeah what's the matter mom any  loss for instagram followers today oh  and i'm dying sit down I'll give you the  deets why are you dying death is like  life you know death just like happens I  don't know if what I said just made any  sense we all have like a destiny not my  [ __ ] friend destiny like gods destiny  what's my destiny malt leaf is a box of  chocolates forest you start out as a man  then once you're eligible for Social  Security become a woman mama always had  a way of explaining things so I could  understand them I'll miss you forest she  had got the cancer and died on a Tuesday  I bought her new hat with little flowers  on it forest what the hell this doesn't  match my funeral alpha at all oh well  deathbed selfie